car philippe labro est un écrivain qui
aiment le cinéma il a réalisé plusieurs
films et le cinéma le lui rend bien
l'étudiant étranger passe du mot à
l'image l'école cornu langlois bernard
tissot
je me revois je revois ce jeune homme
aux joues et offrons inaltérée un jeune
homme vierge jeter comme l'habitant
d'une autre planète
sur une terre au langage non des
chiffres et aux signes mystérieux il a
18 ans philippe quand il réalise son
rêve étudier dans une université de
virginie aux grands sinistres banques
donnent à l'ignoble runavik à la petite
semaine
des professeurs originaux défi coquine
un copain sportif il découvre la société
sudiste au coeur des années 50
et puis aussi le football américain
c'est pour montrer la force de la
première fois la première fois qu'on
aime la première fois qu'on découvre
l'amitié la première fois on découvre la
solitude la première fois qu'on découvre
je ne sais pas moi la violence et toutes
ces choses là évidemment ma seule la
jeunesse faut les vivre
donc je suis plutôt c'est un gamin et
donc quand je vois ça quand je vois la
retraduction de ce sentiment très fort
de la première fois j'en ai un tout
petit pincement au coeur
bonjour
c'est très étrange et je dis ça parce
que c' est capable de nourrir des dons
dédiés ils découvrent aussi l'amour et 7
relations interraciales amérique oblige
prend une place prédominante et v
c'était intéressant et difficile de
jouer ce rôle cariou scénariste mais nos
meilleurs et la réalisatrice ont donné à
cette histoire d'amour beaucoup plus
d'ampleur que dans le livre
ils ont donc pris quelques libertés
mais je crois que c'est en accord avec
philippe labro kobe c'est bien sûr très
belle mais joue très bien la comédie et
apporte à ce personnage toute la finesse
et toute l'amertume nécessaire c'est
qu'elle sait très bien qu'à des
s'embarquent dans son aventure amoureuse
et que ce jeune français que ça ne peut
pas durer que c'est complètement
dangereux donc provisoire lui en
revanche innocent et naïf comme il croit
que c'est pour la vie et ça c'est plutôt
bien en nombre bien décrite aussi sa
rencontre avec le jazz et sa conquête
douloureuse de la maturité